[Applause]
yeah that's how dame lillard and
portland knocked out paul george and okc
of the playoffs last year the american
express teammates not exactly teammates
uh paul george and damien lillard today
as the clippers took on the blazers and
you see
the numbers that they put up but this is
all part of the whole narrative so here
comes
here goes dame lillard down one
he's going to go to the line with the
chance to give him the lead but misses
the first so now he needs to hit this
one just to tie
and this guy shoots nearly 90 from the
line and he missed
them both and patrick beverly is
absolutely loving it
playing the whole game time thing and
everything else and then dame misses
and the game is over and dame had this
to say
to me that just shows what they expect
from me down the stretch you know
they know what i do he saw it firsthand
when i was a second year player when he
was in houston
so i'm sure he has a great memory that
paul george just got sent home
by me last year in the playoffs so they
know that the reason they reacting like
that is because of what they expect from
me which is the sign of respect
and it just shows what i've done at a
high clip more times than not so
i'm not offended by it if anything it
should just tell you how
how much it hurt them to go through what
i put them through in those situations
that was just that was just the start of
it
god damn pat bevin we're gonna be a
cancun on three
from from pat bev uh and paul george
and you're getting sent home this year
he says
hi pg miller comes back out
keep switching teams running from the
grind your
oh but then here's paul george that too
in my stint with my first team i had
more success
name time running out
and then uh as if to kind of smooth
things that work
how that smooth ass can't be smoothed
out exactly explain
things and a lot of jawn going on
imagine going through six surgeries and
still be standing i promise the story
would be different if that never
happened
but respected injuries part of the game
i play i leave it on the floor every
time i suit up
god bless
[Laughter]
biggie
[Music]
that bubble down there is giving some
cabin fever these guys
travel chuck me the ticket to the bubble
ticket to the bubble asap what do you
think of all this dream on
uh i mean i think dame had a valid point
you know he
he said nothing but facts and on the
flip side um
patrick beverly and paul george their
favorites to win this year so
they got to complete the task but it's i
love it
look look let me tell you first of all
dame is not going to back down from he's
a rap battle
this is a rap battle he's never going to
back down from that but patrick beverly
does what he does that he is an irritant
on the court off the court
in the in in in the uh in a green room
wherever he's going to be so the
expectation was it
i think it got interesting when paul
george jumped in
because that is not what we expect from
him we expected from pat we expected
from dame
we he battled shaq in a battle so we
understand what they're going to do
but when he jumped in that really
incited it to a different
level i knew it was something when i
came in and chuck was talking about
something that's on social media
you know they were showing me listen i'm
with dame all the way he's a bad man
he missed a couple of free till today
but his records speak for himself
hey he's gonna get a chance i i hate to
be the next team to come out
no no no chuck trying not to have a diss
track like shaq han
i won't no no no no no they ain't really
damn real of course
pg can't talk about surgeries after all
no you can't come here to play the
sympathy card
no no you can't complain hey no you
can't commit a crime then ask for a plea
deal hey come on
you got to go to the jury we do i don't
know we do not have a post-game shot
we don't have a post-game show today so
no right now we say hey thank you